e aí galera com seu canal pra vocês a
esses dias eu estava andando no shopping
total do shopping etapa e eu percebi uma
coisa eu comecei a evitar entrar nas
lojas porque comecei a gritar na loja
por causa do vendedor muitas vezes eu
não sei se o vendedor sá mas muitas
vezes na maioria das vezes as pessoas
entram na loja pensando assim eu não
conheço essa hoje que eu entrar vou ver
o que é que tem caso algo me agrade eu
comprarei só que você entra na loja e
sempre uma pessoa que todo empregado
atendente de loja se tem duas semana
quer mostrar serviço você botou para
dentro da loja por essa aquela pessoa
que geralmente é de baixa estatura
pequenininha está muito empolgado com o
trabalho dela se pode prestar atenção
que a pessoa que trabalha há anos da
loja não tá nem aí pra você então
ficavam os atendentes de loja novo ele
briga para ver quem vai atender em xeque
não foi ontem e não é o que o mundo já
foi da outra filha de um item schewinski
do maracujá o trabalho realizado na loja
e outra história quando não vai na tua
mas eu toco mero um deus anta gorda
notou a diferença no 8 do pãozinho
atenção de alguma coisa de bom tá usando
coisas em ottawa onde precisa de alguma
coisa
de uma coisa você fala não tinham que
dançar olha aqui porque você fala isso é
automático é da nossa cabeça às vezes
mais muitas vezes a gente está dando só
uma olhadinha só ela falou assim ah tá
tudo bonfim cantá está praticando tai só
que ela não te deixa à vontade só porque
porque ela ficou olhando o que você está
olhando como você escolhe uma coisa que
a pessoa tá te olhando da hora você fica
que escolhem as coisas sob ótica
montagem pode beleza que que a já tô
olhando aqui as coisas que tap pode lá
para depois ou coisa que o valha aqui
não assim também
a vontade é você pega uma caneta olha a
gente tem caneta de 3 ficou em vermelho
e azul têm dessas aqui colorido tem tudo
a ver com o cheirinho a gente tem vários
conector da moranguinho é falando eu só
dar uma olhada aqui só pegando mesma
caneta tocando só ps naquela estação a
tudo bem não pode ficar à vontade eu
fico incomodado tive que mexer nas
coisas que me imputar
o run méxico a olhar as coisas se
encosta de um caderno
a gente tem vários cadernos a gente tem
caderno de um senhor gente tem caderno
de snowboard
a neve é um caco de cada dia chegando
nova e que é nova tv nacional exclusiva
da nossa marca que é um campo liso fi
histórico quem vai escapar e caderno bom
capa dura talvez e que está fazendo essa
transição agora de caderno de capa mole
pra casa de catador que é um dândi tá
grande mudança que podia pegar escada
nem sempre foi do batman eu só tô
olhando moça eu não ainda não me
interesse pessoal todo dando uma olhada
a abom itália onde pode escolher aquela
coisa feita com um retoque alguma coisa
o senhor já escolheu o senhor já começou
em algumas blusas nessa meu tamanho que
está em você se desdobra blusa bota que
o pior é a cara de culpa da atendente
que ficou então você se que depois de
tudo que a rumo é você continua olhando
vendo porque essas coisas você realmente
do [ __ ] dia é quando você finalmente
encontrou se com passa pelo meu deus
esta caneca
meu deus do céu é uma caneca do esquenta
bola o péricles quando os outros
integrantes da banda
eita só deu péricles aí fala moça conta
que essa boneca que é só conectar de 289
a a abom
[Música]
eu vou deixar ela kiko não vou indicar
que eu vou lhe procurar uma mãe caiu eu
vejo o seu controle é uma tática que a
gente tem disse que vai procurar a mãe
da gente não volta mas nunca o que eu
acho melhor de tudo a gente ficar
evitando passar na frente a essa lógica
o medo da pb de reconhecer falasse ei só
chic ataque guardado e você vai comprar
um chiqueiro tem condição cada compra
nas lojas ou cantar olhando
a oic mas essa pedra um cara conta que
essa pec moça a essa pedra já está
fazendo de quatrocentos e setenta e dois
reais e de direita tudo é 2 e vai sair
da loja ainda falei não vai levar a
pedra andré 2 4 6 e também a senhora uma
pedra de crack é mais barato que essa
crise é evitar modo cada atendente o dia
desse um sexy shop perto da minha casa é
todo dia eu ir pra casa estava lotada do
shopping voltar de algum trabalho
passava perto de casa que é que esse sex
shops campeia e onde eu pensei eu falei
mesmo pude no sangue shopping nem ver
como é que é esse show só que eu fico
preocupada com um atendente ou não tenho
paciência para em sexshop um tempo aí eu
fui quando eu entrei no sexy shop meu
amigo atendente do sexy shop
era um senhor eu nunca tinha entrado
sete shoppings não sabe onde é que eu
começar a olhar como pensava que não já
estava na rua de borra a minha falou em
que eu te mostro as coisas falei não não
ela já pegou um negócio assim esse gel
aqui é muito bom para masturbação
masculina você passa aqui na grande e
pode começar a fazer é olhar apoiava ó
isso por dentro e por fora para assim
poder tolo e esse é muito bom ter mais
preocupação feminino você coloque em
cima e pode começar o a ha ha ha ha ha
louro entende um é um problema de
certeza que eu tenho uma imaginação
muito fértil eu tenho uma imaginação
poderosa e tocou na veia pega e faz isso
aqui na minha frente na minha cabeça
sobre um filme pornô com 35 vm tortura
em esse vibrador que é muito bom que ele
vem com esse plug como se fosse um dedo
anal por fora tal honra agora por dentro
na não cuidava não vá você pode tudo
deixa ele vibrando em cima do clítoris
como fazem a incisão anauá ligado no
estado que eu fui pra casa não sendo tão
ligado no estado que eu fui para casa e
fui pra casa
i o 2011 esqueci aquela que eu assim eu
não tenho nada contra a rainha que faz
sexo não tenho nada contra mas também
não tenho nada a favor na saída em uma
casa títulos e sabe que esse shopping um
monte de cor de borracha na band e eu vi
meu amigo uma tora desse tamanho que eu
falei ontem não tem condição não tem
outra opção que com o negócio é não ter
um preferido até um buraco nem eu peguei
para tirar foto e mandar o jogo é teu
pai jonathan e pensando em comprar esse
aqui eu peguei desse tamanho de sua mãe
peguei aqui segura aqui no momento que
essa circunferência aqui eu tirei a foto
que comandava joão neto a escrever a
legenda que segundo ela nesse meio tempo
e trouxe a atendente da loja só que essa
é a mais nova ela olhou pra mim e falou
assim tudo é ruim do sul
só que essa média já são acostumados a
que todo mundo e todo mundo quer tirar
onda com essas gôra mortal estava no meu
e só que eu não sabia disso a minha tia
me pego com a mão na massa pra mim que
eu estava na minha mão na cabeça dela o
que eu desejava o resto da minha vida
ela falou tirar foto comigo nem fora
porque não parecendo sexshop lá dentro
até fora eu vou explicando para a final
fiquei na caminhada é norte americana de
romã e foi alcançado mandar aniversário
unicamente ela sim sim eu tô ligado não
é só brincar e conhecer e rolando manoel
não gosta não gosto de ver ambos ficam
num golpe e não sei eu também não
precisa se explicar não não estou
falando que eu só tô sabendo que eu não
é o que eu gosto entendeu que eu gosto é
da mulher cuja mulher que a mulher
atendida nas escolhas e eu muito menos
tamanho não não um é tão fã sério na
casa de mim eu não gosto eu sei que
consigo tranquilo você acredite em mim
eu tô com filhos segurança acredita em
mim todo mundo dançar então é isso esse
foi o vídeo de hoje você clica em gostei
a quitar no youtube você está aqui na
telinha do youtube tem um dedinho assim
pra cima sempre pelo celular
a pergunta do que gostei daqui que é
muito importante para mim porque você
comente aqui em baixo com focou mais
interessante mais engraçado mais
constrangedora que já aconteceu com você
em alguma loja fica no twitter vão bater
de novo aquele record eu botei 5.000 rt
da outra vez ela bateu record agora eu
queria um recorde de 10 mil st
você quer no twitter líquida retweet aí
você no facebook clique em curtir nós se
inscreve no canal não perder nunca o
vídeo novo
valeu é nóis